[Musik]
der presseclub mit jörg schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind an diesem sonntagmittag die
sehnsucht nach guten nachrichten war
lange nicht so groß fast alles was in
der welt passiert gibt anlass zur sorge
macht vielen menschen angst und
wahrscheinlich hat deshalb die nachricht
so viel aufmerksamkeit gefunden dass die
ukraine in einer gegenoffensive im
nordosten des landes tausende
quadratkilometer befreit zurückerobert
hat die russischen angreifer hatten
monate gebraucht um diesem land schrift
landstrich zu besetzen er fiel binnen
weniger tage ist dass die gute nachricht
ist dass die wende im krieg rückt uns
das näher an den frieden oder zumindest
an das ende des mordens und
blutvergießens oder ist es einfach nur
eine der vielen wendungen die kriege
haben wie auch immer die politische
debatte hat sich in den letzten tagen
durch die neue lage an der front
deutlich verändert der druck auf
bundeskanzler scholz wächst aus der nato
aus washington vor allem aus der eigenen
koalition
endlich die lieferung von kampfpanzern
freizugeben die bereitstünden die sofort
exportiert werden könnten und die
möglicherweise der ukraine gerade jetzt
hilfreich zur seite stehen können und
unser presseclub thema heute ukraine auf
dem vormarsch scholz unter druck welche
rolle spielt die bundesrepublik
deutschland und das sind die gäste auf
die ich mich freue
martin benninghoff ist bei uns er leitet
das politikressort bei der frankfurter
rundschau herzlich willkommen gesine
dornblüth sie ist freie journalistin war
als korrespondentin für das
deutschlandradio in moskau stefan götz
richter ist wieder am tisch herausgeber
und chefredakteur des online-magazins
der global lässt und ich begrüße thomas
wiegold er schreibt den blog augen
geradeaus über sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik ist freier
journalist und herbie gold jemand der
aus der ferne einschätzen kann was sich
militärisch in den letzten tagen
verändert hat ist ihnen das klar können
sie das beschreiben
na ja wir haben einen einen groben
einblick wir wissen nicht alle details
das ist wahrscheinlich in dieser
situation auch nicht zu erwarten die
ukraine hat erfolge erzielt das ist
unbestritten ob es wirklich dauerhaft
sein kann das wissen wir eben noch nicht
ein wichtiger punkt ist und da wird eben
interessant es gibt nicht nur
geländegewinne es gibt ein fluss der
ukraine gewinne kontrolle über
nachschublinien und das zählt eigentlich
viel mehr als wie viele städte sind
befreit worden wie viele
quadratkilometer wurden erobert die
frage ist kann der russische nachschub
der sehr stark auf eisenbahn angewiesen
ist kann der so geschwächt werden
gestoppt unterbrochen dass diese erfolge
im nordosten sich auf andere regionen
auswirken auf den bass auf den süden und
das wird die fragen in den nächsten
tagen von bedeutung sein wird frau
doppel die ist ihre beobachtung ihrer
einschätzung ja ja ich hatte einen ganz
wichtigen punkt gemacht ich denke es hat
sich wirklich gezeigt in den letzten
tagen dass die ukraine und die russen
auf unterschiedliche art und weise krieg
führen die russen auf die alte ich sag
mal sowjetische art und weise viele
leute nach vorne und dann gucken wir mal
was passiert und befehl ist befehl und
die ukraine haben sehr
ausgeklügelt und sehr fein tariert und
sehr strategisch agiert insbesondere
indem sie mit präzisions schlägen im
russischen hinterland eben die erwähnten
nachschubwege abgeschnitten haben und
ich denke das kommt jetzt hängt viel
davon ab ob sie das so weiterführen
können herr benninghoff die ukrainische
armee hat weniger waffen weniger
soldaten weniger munition als die große
russische wie ist es trotzdem gelungen
haben sie nach einschätzung der zunächst
einmal ist die ukrainische armee nach
2014 gestärkt worden ist trainiert
worden vor allen dingen von den
amerikanern großbritannien dazu kommt
noch ein großer moralischer effekt
offenbar der der
funktioniert und der auch dazu führt
dass mit dem schwächeren material
einfach einen aus der ukrainischen sicht
besseres ergebnis erzielt wird uns
sicherlich auch haben die
waffenlieferungen zum teil aus
deutschland dazu beigetragen herr
richter vor drei wochen an diesem tisch
da was genau der jahrestag ein halbes
jahr seit beginn dieses angriffskriegs
da war sich die runde fast einig dass
die ukraine nicht die kraft hätte zu
entscheidenden befreiungsschlägen das
bauch etwas was ja in vielen medien zu
lesen von vielen militärexperten zu
hören war ist das jetzt der ausreißer
oder ist es die fehleinschätzung
ich hoffe dass das was aktuell passiert
die richtige einschätzung ist denn auch
aus sicht derer die in deutschland zur
vorsicht mahnen militärisch gilt hier
einsatz weiterhin dass jeglicher friede
in der diplomatie den sachstand auf dem
schlachtfeld zu direct ist das zu sehen
reflektieren wird daher sind alle
deutschen argumente dass wir nicht
weiter eskalieren sondern wird jetzt
zurückhalten sollen wo die ukraine
möglicherweise gelingt das momentum zu
ändern weil sie eben militärisch
geschickt sind während die russen wollen
offensichtlich seit 1945 nichts
dazugelernt haben außer dass sie viel
geld ausgegeben haben für die rüstung
dadurch einmal nur weil sie laden wort
gesagt haben dass vielleicht der
schlüssel ist und kurz fragen wird ist
dass die ansicht also ist die ukraine
geschickt wenngleich schwächer ist das
der punkt das ist eine frage von
geschick und übung so haben sie es
formuliert aber bitte ich habe sie
unterbrochen es ist geschick es ist auch
sehr kluge westliche unterstützung
gerade von seiten der usa denn die haben
natürlich eine fantastische situation
jetzt überlegen wir uns mal der
russische präsident bricht einen krieg
vom zaun und der ganze westen hat bisher
immer gerade wir deutschen vor den
russen und die militärische angriffe
angst gehabt und wir stellen fest dass
das im wesentlichen eine brutalisierung
maschine ist die ganzen
modernisierungsinvestitionen
offensichtlich zum guten teil in
korruption gelandet sind und das sollte
uns im westen große zuversicht geben
denn auch bezüglich der befürchtung dass
wenn jetzt wir weiter machen die russen
irgendwelchem material ischen
gegenschläge machen die russen haben
regelrecht geschreddert aus eigenem
antrieb und ich glaube die amerikaner
haben sehr geschickt immer soviel dazu
gegeben dass die ukraine genug hatten um
das voll auszureizen und auf dem moment
müssen wir weiter beharren im eigenen
interesse denn der aggressor ist
natürlich nur russland danke für die
erste runde danke allen die im
livestream bei presse.de tagesschau.de
dabei sind ich lese wie immer parallel
was so ein rückmeldungen von ihnen kommt
und versuche das hier in die runde eins
zu bringen ich habe es eingangs gesagt
die politische diskussion in der
bundesrepublik hat sich schlagartig
verändert das ist die deutung von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz diese woche im
interview der woche im deutschlandfunk
wir tun sehr sehr viel und zwar das was
dazu geführt hat dass jetzt sich die
situation militärisch verändert hat das
darf und muss glaube ich auch
festgehalten werden gerade die waffen
die wir zur verfügung gestellt haben
haben den unterschied gemacht und die
jetzigen erfolge die die ukraine
verzeichnet auch ermöglicht und deshalb
macht es auch sinn dass wir dort weiter
machen ansonsten gilt generell ein
grundsatz der mir sehr wichtig ist wir
werden bei allem was wir tun keine
alleingänge machen der benninger auf das
was wir geliefert haben hat diesen
erfolg der ukraine ermöglicht sagt der
bundeskanzler
ja ich glaube da hat er auf jeden fall
nicht unrecht es ist ein beitrag aber
natürlich nur weil man muss das
vielleicht mal von vorne aufziehen man
sieht ja angesichts der bilder die wir
auch nochmal aus der ukraine sehen eine
große große ohnmacht bei uns allen und
in der debatte in deutschland hat es
sich ein stück weit verschoben dass man
eben aus dieser ohnmacht heraus versucht
die kritik besonders zu überziehen
gegenüber der bundesregierung ja wobei
es ist eine ganz klare militärische
frage also deutsche waffen das
ermöglicht das jetzt passiert es sei
also als beitrag ja nicht mehr als wie
bereits sagte
aber die überzogene kritik an der
bundesregierung sagt er genau das
gegenteil gesagt ja im grunde genommen
wenn ich mal überspitzte ist die
bundesregierung hat sich der
unterlassenen hilfeleistung
schuldig gemacht und da würde ich sagen
das ist maßlos überzogen wir sehen die
bundesregierung hat relativ viel
geliefert auch dass wir können jetzt da
die einzelnen waffengattungen
durchgehend fenster sind dabei haubitzen
es gibt jetzt auch ein neues atelier
system ausgeliefert werden soll was
allerdings lange dauert das muss man
dazu sagen es gibt ein ringtausch über
griechenland mit mit panzern das jetzt
auf die kampfkunst diskussion zu
reduzieren halte ich für überzogen wir
müssen erstmal gucken was die
bundesregierung wirklich gemacht hat war
dort wird er wegen der richter ja ich
denke
was man auf jeden fall betonen muss ist
das auch aus der ukraine her große
anerkennung kommt gerade für die
deutschen haubitzen und auch für die
gebhard panzer das wird man immer wieder
von verschiedenen institutionen von ganz
verschiedenen ebenen also eine total
verriss der deutschen haltung ist es
nicht aber deutschland hat natürlich
viel vertrauen verspielt über die monate
worauf ich eingehen möchte ist dass das
die argumente von bundeskanzler die wir
hören weshalb wir jetzt eben nicht die
leopard 2 panzer und die marder liefern
sollten dass die einfach nicht
überzeugend sind jedenfalls für mich
nicht und ich glaube für viele andere
auch nicht das argument keine
alleingänge da gibt es ja jetzt schon
seit einer woche ein lassen sie uns da
als nächstes draufgehen ich bin noch mal
bei der klärung der frage weil ich lese
es zum beispiel auch bei twitter von
matthias rehfeld was hat deutschland
denn nun gemacht irgendwie gibt es wenig
infos die nicht immer sofort gewertet
werden da stimmt herr wie gold
deutschland hat 24 gebaut flach panzer
für henry fällt jetzt 24 gebhard flaig
panzer sechs kommen noch zehn
panzerhaubitze 2000 bislang drei
demnächst fünf mehrfach raketenwerfer
mit insgesamt wenn ich richtig rechne
500 schuss also 500 raketen munition ob
plus flieger fäuste panzerfäuste und so
weiter es ist nicht nichts es ist eine
menge trotzdem muss man sagen wenn man
sich die statistik die rangfolge der
staaten militärische leistungen
lettieris lieferung anschaut
kommt usa hier ist klar
großbritannien polen kanada deutschland
also so zu tun als sei deutschland in
der spitzengruppe da muss man
realistisch sein ein und der zweite
punkt das schließt dann an das
vielleicht anders gleichkommt
deutschland hat sich zulieferung bereit
erklärt immer dann wenn man eigentlich
schon ein bisschen gedrängt wurde diese
gepard flugabwehr panzer die wurden
zugesagt beim ersten rammstein treffen
mit dass schon ein paar wochen her paar
monate her aber da gucken alle auf
deutschland was macht ihr denn und dann
zauberte die verteidigungsministerin
diese gepaart flugabwehr panzer aus dem
hut die gar nicht der bundeswehr gehören
sondern die bei der industrie stehen und
so ähnlich ist das auch ja erst drei
mehrfach raketenwerfer dann diese woche
noch zwei mehr was der bundeswehr wehtut
aber das ist eine andere frage also man
hat schon den eindruck ja viel tun oder
einiges tun aber immer dazu getragen
wird ich verstehe aber sehr gut die
wahrnehmung oder scholz gerade eben
gehört im interview stellt es so dar
dass es die wesentlichen beiträge sind
sie haben gerade die rangfolge sozusagen
was die menge angeht so knopf aufgezählt
herr giegold herr richter in der
koalition in berlin gibt es ja auch
unterschiedliche sichtweisen die fdp
verteidigungsexpertin marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann wirft scholz zögern
und zaudern vor also was nun starke
stütze oder zögern und zaudern und anton
hofreiter und so weiter ich glaube was
der kanzler und wie allgemeine der
deutschen diskussion bisher noch völlig
aus den augen verloren haben ist die
tatsache wie er denn die weggefährten
von herrn scholz in der panzer frage
sind heutzutage
das ist die afd und das ist die partei
die linke in der spd gibt es einen
politiker den sehr ehrenwerten michael
roth der sich dafür einsetzt
der rest der staat sich dazu musste und
jetzt vorsitzende des auswärtigen
ausschusses der eine einzelmeinung hat
dass eine moderne sozialdemokratische
partei sich mit solchen genossen um
geben will bei dieser frage ist für mich
erstaunlich ist auch erstaunlich der
kollege hat eben gerade gesagt dass wir
immer hinten dranhängen wenn ich die
geschichte die stolze antifaschistisch
antifaschistische geschichte der spd
verstehe dann muss man sich eigentlich
gehören faschistisches regime im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert werden und
da sind wir sehr nah an russland dran
und dass man vor dem hintergrund und den
deutschen angriffskrieg den es damals
gegen die ukraine gegeben hat denn wie
hat denn das letzte mal einen so
brutalen krieg gegen die ukraine
lanciert vor den russen das waren wir
deutsche das sollte gerade für eine
moderne sozialdemokratie zu ganz anderen
schlussfolgerungen führen als wir von
olaf scholz vernehmen da habe ich mal
eine gegenposition dazu bringen ich
möchte mal das beispiel der usa nehmen
die sie ja sehr gut kennen die usa haben
auf einer anderen ebene eine ähnliche
debatte da geht es nicht um panzer da
geht es um raketen diese sogenannten
army tactical miss als die fliegen etwa
300 kilometer weit und da haben die usa
gesagt liebe ukraine er drängt ihr wollt
wir haben aber wir geben die euch nicht
das hat der präsident glaube ich gestern
oder vorgestern noch einmal bekräftigt
um eben eine eskalation gegenüber
russland zu vermeiden moment lassen sie
mich das konto geführt
nun ist das in gewisser weise
nachvollziehbar weil mit diesen raketen
russische ziele in direkter reichweite
der ukraine rücken gerade deswegen würde
ich aber die deutsche debatte auch wenn
sie so ähnlich scheint ein bisschen
anders einsortieren wenn wir über
kampfpanzer reden oder über
schützenpanzer reden wir über waffen auf
dem gefechtsfeld wir reden nicht über
einen möglichen angriff auf russland und
deswegen da an der stelle würde ich will
nicht wieder bei ihnen die in gefahr
einer eskalation darin zu sehen das habe
ich noch nicht verstanden das hat mir
der bundeskanzler auch noch nicht
erklären können ist etwas was ich auch
in vielen rückmeldungen sehr also ich
fass es mal laienhaft zusammen das eine
sind waffen die der ukraine helfen
können den angriff zurückzuschlagen ohne
selbst bedrohung für russische städte zu
sein das andere werden waffen mit denen
man weit in russland auch schaden
anrichten könnte also sozusagen mit
gleicher münze zurückzahlen
das tun was die russen in der ukraine
auch getan haben verdoppelt wie viel
angst oder vorsicht steckt in der
haltung der bundesregierung hier gibt es
etwa auch die frage von
wird die bundesregierung anders handeln
wenn wir selbst atommacht wären also wie
viel angst vor einem atomschlag anderen
schlägen der russen steckt da drin das
ist ein thema seit beginn des jahres
oder seit beginn dieses groß angelegten
überfalls und es ist auch so dass von
russischer seite immer wieder gedroht
wurde das kann man sich übrigens in
einer auflistung des des spp genau
angucken helfen sie mir ich gerade die
abkürzung nicht hin ja das ist
eigentlich das institut der
bundesregierung der leistung von
sicherheitspolitik kranke analysiert und
den ministerien zur verfügung stellen so
große empfehlungen gibt es gibt eine
auflistung der verschiedenen
eskalationen drohungen zu rücknahmen von
russischer seite und von westlicher
seite deeskalation und so weiter da kann
man die äußerung nachlesen und präsident
putin hat am 24 02 gesagt sinngemäß wer
sich uns in den weg stellt der dem
werden wir mit der größten härte
begegnen nicht dass zitiere ich jetzt
nicht wörtlich und das hat ja später
noch mal wiederholt und ich denke das
ist etwas was immer wieder mit schwingt
aber man muss sich ja auch klar machen
also es wurde auch gegen westliche
waffenlieferungen so gedroht es wurde
auch gedroht im fall einer
nato-mitgliedschaft der nördlichen
staaten und das ist ja nicht passiert
das muss man auch mal realistisch so
sehen und ich denke es ist einfach ein
machtinstrument putins dass er droht
dass er mit dem atom status des landes
droht sich auch größer macht als das
land ist und er spielt mit den ängsten
mit unseren ängsten die ich natürlich
auch habe aber es heißt auch immer
wieder man muss diese drogen wahrnehmen
aber eine eskalation von russischer
seite ist unwahrscheinlich dass hört man
immer wieder auch von westlichen
geheimdiensten lässt sich trainer berlin
hofft der generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr enger vertrauter von kanzler
scholz herzog
sieht das zumindest anders weil er im
focus interview sagt es könne durchaus
eine zweite front geben angriff auf nato
staaten etwa in der ostsee in der gegend
von kaliningrad wird bei der nato
irritiert zur kenntnis genommen aber ja
also das heißt stolz ist doch
zurückhaltend bei der angst hat vor
russischen zügen also er ist zumindest
nah dran an scholz und insofern muss man
das erstmal zur kenntnis nehmen er hat
gesagt ungefähr 60 prozent der
russischen landstreitkräfte sind
gebunden die nato wieder spricht und
spricht von rund 80 oder mehr ja das
dann ist die lage schon mal anders aber
zumindest ist ein hinweis darauf wie
urlaub scholz denkt und nicht nur er
allein sie haben gerade über die ängste
gesprochen
das ist normal interessanter punkt auch
weil die spd zum beispiel ist ja nicht
michael roth gegen den rest der partei
man die spd ist ungefähr gespalten weil
er bei der panzer frage und da kommen
natürlich genau diese ängste hoch und
ich persönlich um das nochmal
aufzugreifen zauderer und zögerer finde
es richtig dass ein bundeskanzler eben
sich nicht als zauderer gibt der aus
unwissenheit oder aus unsicherheit
abwartet aber zögert und sozusagen auch
die innerparteiliche situation
mit einbezieht und daraus eine
entscheidung ab ab leiteten das kann
auch mal dauern das sind schuldig mehr
aus ärmeren herreweghe als herr richter
darum warum soll die innerparteiliche
situation der spd also sie tut es
faktisch aber warum soll sie eine solche
entscheidung die ganz deutschland
betrifft die auch die nato betrifft und
natürlich auch die ukraine bestimmen das
ist ein punkt an dem ich sage
erst das land dann die partei vielleicht
zumal hinzu kommt dass die spd
inzwischen eine 17 prozent partei ist
der kanzler nach dem letzten umfragen
die ich gesehen habe von 13 prozent der
bevölkerung als kanzler favorisiert wird
aber ich möchte was anderes sagen herr
scholz muss etwas dazu sagen natürlich
weil ich wollte das ist jetzt sie sagen
wie es sein sollte aber ich beschreibe
gerade die situation und die partei die
den bundeskanzler stellt ist die spd und
dass der bundeskanzler auch im hinblick
auf einen landtagswahlkampf darauf
schaut ist als teil der analyse richtig
aber nicht der strategischen frage und
ich möchte auf diese zusammenhänge
eingehen und insbesondere für die frage
wann herr scholz sich hinter den
amerikanern versteckt denn er ist ein
sehr taktischer mensch dabei in der ard
gab es bei dem wahlkampf oriel im
letzten jahr werden die ihre co
moderatorin hat das gemacht zum thema
europa die dezidierte frage an herrn
scholz wie das mit russischem gas
aussieht und er sagte wörtlich von
amerikanischer seite wird immer
behauptet dass wir von russischem gas zu
sehr abhängig sein das ist falsch
darüber sollte sind deutschland
eigentlich in die größere diskussion
geben jetzt sich hinter den amerikanern
zu verstecken halte ich wirklich für
frage der man sagt wer bei mir führung
bestellt erhält eine großartige
zeitenwende rede und da gibt es vier es
dazu zu beachten die ein kanzler helmut
schmidt sicherlich in reden danach
behandelt hätte frieden und freiheit
furcht und feigheit und da wird in
deutschland überhaupt nicht darüber
gesprochen wir sind nach 1945 haben wir
die freiheit als geschenk der amerikaner
bekommt muss man wirklich sagen wir
haben danach die sicherheitskomponente
von den amerikanern bekommen das heißt
man könnte sagen wir sind überhaupt
nicht daran gewöhnt im unterschied zu
den ost europäern und den baltischen
staaten und den usa und großbritannien
für die freiheit jemals gekämpft zu
haben aber auch eine spd müsste genau an
der stelle eigentlich sehen die immer
sagt wir sind eine so tolle europa
orientierte partei das in ganz europa im
prinzip die anti hitler koalition
gegen uns steht in dieser frage und das
sollte vor dem hintergrund der deutschen
geschichte und der deutschen
militärischen aggression in 21
jahrhundert konsequenzen haben und man
sollte sich nicht immer hinter den
amerikanern verstecken denn die sache
natürlich passt mal auf panzer
das wird dir über geschickt haben ihr
habt die tut mal was stellen weil
irgendein führungsanspruch muss nochmal
einlösen man kann ich wie die
verteidigungsministerien die so wirkt
auf einmal als schutz mutter der nation
was völlig unüberlegt des performativ
die eine frau die aus hessen süd kommt
und deshalb auf den
verteidigungsminister posten gekommen
ist und der linke spd frau dort zu haben
die immer gegen die zwei prozent war und
so weiter die jetzt sagt wir müssen alle
unsere waffen wieder aus der ukraine
zurückbekommen ich verstehe die spd mit
ihrem anspruch auf aufklärung
realität fairness und mut in europa
überhaupt nicht mehr herr benning habe
ich gebe ihnen noch eine frage mit ja
zur entgegnung also zunächst mal haben
sie finde ich den konflikt sehr gut
beschrieben ich würde auch mit zwei auf
einem vogel app beschreiben vorsicht
oder feigheit also das scheinen ja so
die beiden leitungen der politik zu sein
ich lese ich ja immer wieder die frage
warum können sich grüne und fdp nicht
durchsetzen wenn auch die größte
oppositionspartei die union eindeutig
jetzt einen anderen schritt möchte
zunächst aber muss man ja glaube ich
beschreiben dass die grünen ja eine ganz
ganz klare haltung haben was ja auch
erstmal ein bisschen verwundert also es
sind offenbar auch die jüngeren bei den
grünen ich sehe eine gewisse distanz von
leuten wie trittin der alten garde zu
der waffen frage die einfach eine ganz
andere haltung haben und ich glaube man
versucht die jetzt noch ein jahr nach
der bundestagswahl den koalitionsfrieden
halbwegs gerade zu halten
wie lange das hält kalter tag lauter und
öffentlich ja die wird öffentlicher und
man hat sie auch jetzt gesehen noch
zwischen der außenministerin und dem
kanzler da scheint sich möglicherweise
etwas anzubahnen aber zunächst einmal
versucht nur noch die harmonie zu halten
dann hat mich nochmal was bekommt etwas
argumentationshilfe liefern apropos
furcht oder vorsicht wir erleben ja
zurzeit einen wladimir putin der
geschwächt ist wie nie ich weiß nicht ob
sie gesehen haben die bilder aus nahm
erkannt von dem gipfel in usbekistan da
haben wir gesehen dass wladimir putin
der sonst alle hat warten lassen auf
vier seiner
kollegen hat warten müssen der sonst
breitbeinig da sitzt mit erdogan
zusammen in der pressekonferenz wurde
von erdogan untergehakt das egal ob er
jetzt aus welchen gründen aber ist das
wäre vor ein paar monaten nicht passiert
putin hat gegenüber dem chinesischen
staatsoberhaupt eingeräumt dass wir eure
sorgen bezüglich der ukraine wahrnehmen
das heißt er weiß ganz genau dass er die
unterstützung auch seiner partner da im
fernen osten nicht hat und erst recht
nicht im fall eines einsatzes von
taktischen atomwaffen da wird china sehr
stark dagegen sein und auch die türkei
würde er damit gegen sich aufbringt das
ist in diesen ganz interessanter aspekt
auf den wir auch noch näher eingehen
sollten aber daraus kann man ja auch
furcht oder vorsicht ableiten man kann
sagen dass ein geschwächter putin
vielleicht noch irrationaler noch
totaler wird oder
dass ihm die kraft dafür fehlt weil er
sorge hat dann niemanden mehr an seiner
seite zu haben er wird ja oft als
irrational dargestellt ich glaube das
ist falsch erfolg seiner eigenen
rationalität das ist nicht unsere aber
ist jetzt keiner der der denke ich um
sich schlägt auszahlen sondern er geht
weiterhin strategisch vor taktisch
vortag durch falsch vor allen dingen
weil er falsch informiert wird aber es
geht ihm weiterhin um machterhalt und
haben sie eine einschätzung ob seine
macht bröckelt ob es risse in seinem
macht fundament gibt es gibt zu unser
aller überraschung im russischen
talkshows plötzlich menschen die ja die
in deutlich kritisieren oder sitzt er
fest im sattel jetzt bröckelt
tatsächlich an einigen ecken das ist
eine sehr interessante phase jetzt und
das haben wir lange lange nicht erlebt
es haben ja auch einige lokalpolitiker
abgeordnete in sankt petersburg und
moskau haben aufforderungen
unterschrieben eine resolution in der er
zum rücktritt aufgefordert wird das wird
meiner meinung nach ein bisschen
überinterpretiert man muss gucken was
man da nicht auch seinem eigenen
wunschdenken anheimfällt
was die talkshows angeht die größte
kritik ist allerdings und das weiß ich
auch von quellen aus der russischen
gesellschaft
die größere kritik geht eher in die
richtung wir müssen jetzt zulegen in
richtung krieg den krieg nicht mehr
beschönigen und verfälschen als
sonderoperation über auch eine
generalmobilmachung und dergleichen mehr
also das ist denke ich die größere
gefahr sind herr richter warum macht
putin das nicht seine truppen sind
geschwächt und er bräuchte dringend
soldatinnen und soldaten und verzichtet
trotzdem auf die mobilmachung auf die
generalmobilmachung wahrscheinlich
deshalb weil in russland nach 20 jahren
despotismus der kleptokratie
selbst die leute in der provinz
verstanden haben dass das russische
system nicht mehr für irgendetwas kämpft
putin und die kosten auch für die
mittelschicht und die obere
mittelschicht immer noch in unseren
skiorten rom fährt und sich tot lacht
über die sanktionen und im sommerurlaub
irgendwie an der côte d'azur und so
weiter mit irgendwie zügen in kompletter
über die türkei die wörter verlieren
aber ich finde eine frage die infra
blauen blüten aufgebracht hat noch mal
interessant zum thema deutsche furcht
denn auch die spd und der kanzler sagt
ja immer irgendwann kann ein nuklear
gehen ich würde das man gerne
durchdeklinieren wenn wir die hypothese
haben dass putin irgendwann nuklear
gehen kann dann müssen wir uns zu
gestehen dass wir im letzten endes die
eskalation dominanz zugestehen und
letzten endes das trotzdem nie
definieren können es gibt keine handlung
die wir machen können wo putin am ende
nicht möglicherweise nuklear irgendetwas
macht weil selbst wenn wir diese ukraine
maschine jetzt im moment auf sparflamme
aber effektiv weiterlaufen lassen seine
hypo tätig ohne deutsche panzer kann es
sein dass sich die gefechtslage so
verändert auch seine situation in
russland das sehr losschlägt aus der
reinen logik von putin das heißt die
logik des kanzlers zu sagen ich habe
angst vor allem russischen atomschlag
ist mir einfach als strategische
komponente nicht begreiflich wilma 1
hinzufügen als manche von uns etwas
jünger waren und die diskussion das
letzte mal war nachrüstung nato
doppelschlag unsere doppelseite da gab
es die these lieber rot als tot wir
müssen uns über eine konsequenz
bewusstsein bei putin wer heutzutage
dann vor ihm deshalb völlig den schwanz
einzieht der sagt faktisch ich bin
lieber brown als tot und ich
argumentiere damit nicht da müsste dafür
das politische risiko eines nuklear
stabs hinzugehen sie sagte mir das lässt
sich so und so nicht kalkulieren aber
wir müssen uns der politischen und
historischen konsequenzen dieser schwanz
knallerei sehr viel deutlicher bewusst
sein und ich werde wiederum nicht dass
ausgerechnet eine spd da auf der
falschen seite der geschichte steht wie
gold
ja ich habe ich glaube wir kommen nicht
weiter wenn wir jetzt 40 jahre zurück
gehen und sagen auf dem hof garten
falsch demonstriert oder so etwas das
das macht ja keinen sinn der punkt ist
einfach dieses thema rationalität und wo
sind die roten linien was könnte putin
bewegen nuklear zu agieren wir wissen es
nicht und wenn man jetzt die vergangenen
vier fünf monate zurückblickt hat jedes
westliche land auch deutschland einiges
getan wo es am anfang hieß können wir
nicht machen das würde diese rote linie
überschreiten die geparden die
panzerhaubitze immer
war vorher die aussage das geht nicht
und dann ging es doch so also die frage
ist was kann man den graduell
weitermachen und dass ich das jetzt auf
diese kampf und schützenpanzer so
fokussiert finde ich ein bisschen
unglücklich also ich vermute sehr stark
wir werden irgendwann in einigen tagen
vielleicht wochen eine entscheidung
sehen zu sagen ja diese marder
schützenpanzer ja warum denn nicht und
ob das nun faktisch möglich ist dass
dann vielleicht auch eine andere frage
da kann man noch gesondert darüber reden
aber da da verschiebt sich einiges
ich würde deswegen ungern in dieser
diese frontstellung des kalten krieges
zu hause noch nicht vorgeschlagen ja so
hill klassiert als location versuch mal
wieder
da wir in wirklich in einer komplexen
lage sind ich finde das hat diese
diskussionsrunde gerade deutlich gemacht
einerseits eben der blick auf westliche
auf deutsche auf nato entscheidungen
andererseits die bewertung der lage in
russland der person putin alles was sie
sagen hinterlässt in mir den schluss es
bleibt unsicher wir werden keine sichere
abschätzung darüber haben wie putin
reagiert das ist das wesen dieses
krieges vielleicht generell das wesen
des krieges insofern muss jede
entscheidung am ende sagen bin ich
bereit das risiko einzugehen
ich glaube es steht eine faszinierende
frage im hinblick auf eigentlich dann
aber kurz ich glaube würde ich sehr
gerne darauf eingehen das haben wir
sehen gleich
die faszinierende frage ist ob diese
ganzen sachen putin einschätzen hamster
ja oder nein und das nicht einfach einen
meter diskussion ist weil sich folgende
partei folgender frage noch nicht
gestellt hat die es das verhältnis der
spd zu russland ist bis heute ungeklärt
und ich werde überhaupt nicht überhand
schröder reden ich würde herrn
steinmeier reden die von herrn graf ist
herr gabriel in der verschiedene sachen
gemacht wie das war sogar kretzschmar
ist nicht in der spd glauben moment aber
ist jedoch nicht nur die
regierungspartei journalisten gemacht
wir hatten ja einen benninghoff
eigentlich die spd eigentlich einen
außenpolitischen gutes berger parteitag
um ihr verhältnis zu russland zu klären
wäre mein vorschlag
mein vorschlag wäre dass sie sich mal an
den spd pressesprecher wenden müssen es
gar nicht an der partei jetzt hier ab
arbeiten meint punkt ist nur die spd als
definiert sich zum teil auch als
friedenspartei das hat natürlich auch
die naivität gegenüber russland
bedingten stück weit wir wissen heute
dass wir beides brauchen diplomatie und
militär und diplomatie wie sie jetzt
beispiel scholz diese woche noch mal
versucht hat wird ja auch lächerlich
gemacht aber ich finde man muss auch
weiterhin selbst mit dem aggressor reden
um zu eruieren ob dieser mann irgendwann
zu einem verhandlungen bereit ist und
das ist sozusagen damals noch mal auf
die spd gehen die historie die ich mir
daraus ziehen würde ich möchte es keine
größere diskussion über die ostverträge
machen wollen aber an der stelle ist die
spd einfach noch auch so definiert dann
bringe ich noch einen punkt ein
frauenbild zu den bildern und worten und
nachrichten dieser woche unser
korrespondent to bleed tobias damals hat
das sehr eindrücklich unter anderem der
tagesschau geschildert gehört das
entdecken erneut von geschändeten
leichen von gräbern mit vielen menschen
die starke vermutung von
kriegsverbrechen der ukrainische
präsident lenski hat an das wüten
deutscher im zweiten weltkrieg vor allem
jahr auf ukrainische boden hin gewesen
wie groß ist der moralische druck und
wie viel kommt da noch in die waagschale
zudem rein rationalen abwägen was wir
gerade gesprochen haben für uns deutsche
ja das kommt ja jetzt erst entgangen das
ist ja eigentlich teil des problems
gewesen über jahre das in deutschland
die sowjetunion mit russland gleich
gesetzt wurde und deswegen gar nicht
bekannt war und oder nicht
akzeptiert werden wollte dass viele der
opfer in der ukraine oder der damaligen
ukrainischen sowjetrepublik ja und der
deutsche angriff galt ja auch der
kornkammer der richtig und belarus in
gleicher weise muss man auch erwähnen
also das sind einfach unterschiede
insofern ist es gut dass dieses
bewusstsein jetzt ein bisschen vordringt
ansonsten bin ich bei herrn richter mit
seinem etwas hier belächelten spruch
also ich war die friesen sagen ja lewa
downs love also lieber tot als sklave
ich glaube das ist ein danke für die
übersetzung
auch wenn es vielleicht übertrieben und
kraß klingt aber ich glaube ein ganz
wichtiger punkt in dieser debatte ist
tatsächlich das bei den deutschen bei
vielen menschen in deutschland und
insgesamt in westeuropa noch nicht
angekommen ist worum es eigentlich geht
was die ukraine aber ganz genau wissen
und jetzt eben wieder vor augen geführt
bekommen mit den gräbern in easy um
unter russischer führung wenn es
russland gelingt sich durchzusetzen ist
kein freiheitliches demokratisches
individualistische
leben in wohlstand möglich russland
setzt sich jetzt schon durch hat
versucht eben
getreideexporte aus der ukraine komplett
zu unterbinden wir haben gesehen was das
für folgen hat insofern glaube ich ist
es unheimlich wichtig auch immer wieder
klar zu machen gar nicht mit dem
moralischen anspruch wir müssen den
ukrainern helfen weil die irgendwie die
angegriffen sind angegriffenen sind und
die kleineren sind und weil wir da was
haben zuschulden kommen lassen gab es
ist auch ein ganz rationales kalkül
einfach wir müssen der ukraine aus
eigeninteresse helfen ich glaube dass
das nicht auf widerspruch stößt hier am
tisch ich würde gerne zum ende der
sendung versuchen mit ihnen den blick in
den nächsten monaten zu werfen merke
aber ja so an den reaktionen wie gold so
eine frage steht dann noch im raum die
sie vielleicht ohne allzu viel in
technische details gehen zu gehen
beantworten können da ist die frage im
raum wie wichtig während deutsche
kampfpanzer jetzt wirklich es wird auch
gefragt da ist von 24 die rede was ist
das für eine zahl in einem krieg das ist
doch lächerlich sein kann keine große
rolle spielen also das was jetzt in
deutschland zu entscheiden ist wie
wichtig ist das für den fortgang also
ganz offensichtlich braucht die ukraine
moderneres sagt mal vorsichtig
westliches gerät um geländegewinne zu
konsolidieren weitere geländegewinne zu
machen also das was sie als offensive
plant
man den panzer müssen vielleicht auch
noch ich will nicht zu technisch werden
trotzdem differenzieren modernste
westliche kampfpanzers leopard 2 halte
ich für relativ unwahrscheinlich oder
nicht kurzfristig machbar weil die sind
in der bundeswehr mangelware die werden
in der bundeswehr oder für die
bundeswehr umgerüstet also dazu sagen
einen neuen würde tiefe einschnitte in
die strukturen der bundeswehr bedeuten
das halte ich für unwahrscheinlich aber
könnte jemand anders die liefern oder
kann ihnen nur von uns kommen die können
auch aus anderen europäischen staaten
also diese diese leopard-kampfpanzer
sind ja relativ weit verbreitet
es wird auch immer wieder gesagt ja wie
wär's denn gemeinsame anstrengungen der
verschiedenen nutzer nationen die müsste
jemand anstoßen vielleicht deutschland
aber ich möchte anderes beispiel nehmen
wenn es möglich ist 40 wieder
hergerichtete marder schützenpanzer
recht kurzfristig griechenland zu
versprechen und griechenland liefert
dafür alte quasi sowjetische
schützenpanzer die technisch doch
deutlich unterlegen sind
dann könnte man doch auch diese 40
panzer schützenpanzer direkt der ukraine
geben dank eine politische frage kein
techno danke für den einschub
habe ich da vor drei wochen habe ich zum
schluss gefragt was wir in den nächsten
monaten auf dem schlachtfeld auch auf
dem politischen feld zu erwarten haben
dies ihre prognose wir müssen und europa
und die usa insbesondere die herren joe
biden hat immer versucht seitdem
olaf scholz in der regierung ist der
immer in washington als unsicherer
kantonist angesehen würde er den immer
versucht zu ermutigen olaf scholz muss
eine konsequenz aus seinem eigenen reden
gerade nach ist jung ziehen und diese
konsequenz heißt ganz einfach er kann
ich wie er im deutschlandfunk interview
dass gerade wieder gesagt hat
er möchte kein diktat schrieben für
russland und gleichzeitig sagt er in
anderen setzen die territoriale
integrität und souveränität der ukraine
soll bewahrt bleiben diese zwei sätze
schließen sich aus das ist ein deutscher
bundeskanzler mit der elegant
intelligenz und erfahrung von olaf
scholz heute noch an der formulierung
von keinem diktat frieden festhält halte
ich für einen politischen skandal in
unserer zeitgeschichte und ich hoffe
dass der kanzler sich sehr wohl sehr
bald eines besseren belehren lässt wenn
er sich von irgendjemanden jemals
belehren es nur von don bleu blick nach
vorn ich glaube meint dem diktat frieden
von russischer seite oder natürlich
meinen blick nach vorne ist wird jetzt
sehr viel davon abhängen was in russland
selber passiert ich sehe das skeptisch
dass sich die russische armee wirklich
stärken kann
präsident putin hat ich glaube gestern
oder vorgestern auch gesagt man werde
jetzt schläge gegen die infrastruktur in
der ukraine
intensivieren das ist sozusagen die
rache und das öffentliche bekenntnis zu
kriegsverbrechen
was die
armeeführung selbst angeht da gibt es
massive probleme mit dem nachschub
russland ist dabei jetzt soldaten zu
rekrutieren in gefängnissen auch
psychisch kranke an die front zu
schicken das ist tragisch aber es ist
wahrscheinlich nichts was die truppe
schlagkräftiger macht
und weiter ein problem bleibt diese
kultur der der lüge in den berichten
oder der verfälschung und nicht der
wahrheit sagen nach oben hin über das
was wirklich an der front passiert regel
der blick nach vorn der wirt der ist
nicht so stark von russland geprägt und
man von der ukraine und die große frage
ist für mich wird die ukraine so
weitermachen können wie in den letzten
zehn tagen in der letzten woche wird sie
den erfolg der ja nicht nur militärische
erfolg ist sondern der auch dem land
hoffnung gibt und auch im westen
natürlich
unterstützung generiert praktisch wird
sie diesen schwung beibehalten können
das haupt setzen können dass du mir
jetzt die entscheidende frage der
nächsten tage und wochen ok und wagen
sie eine einschätzung
einschätzung für die zukunft sind immer
schwierig im moment sieht es gut aus
krieg ist unwägbar dieser krieg ist noch
ein bisschen unwägbare aber im moment
will ich sagen ja herr benninghoff sie
führe ich nicht aufs schlachtfeld
sondern sie sind politikchef also wie es
ihr blick auf die nächsten wochen dass
die innenpolitiker nicht also ich glaube
dass diese waffen debatte die wir heute
hier teilweise geführt haben immer
wieder kommt auch mit den bildern die
die deutsche öffentlichkeit erreichen
ich glaube der krieg da würde ich an sie
anschließend wird teilweise noch
brutaler werden wenn wir sehen nicht nur
kadirow schwanden was sie anstellen
sondern eben auch was mit neuen
rekrutierungs möglichkeiten dort
passiert da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich schwarzen die debatte wird halt
deswegen immer wieder auftauchen ich
wünsche mir dass die
die frage was wir jetzt an waffen
liefern immer wieder neu justiert wird
und besser begründet wird die
kommunikation der bundesregierung war
teilweise grottenschlecht das hat jetzt
nichts mit hessen süd zu tun sondern nur
wenig auch über frau lamprecht wir
machen nichts geht mehr essen süd also
immerhin einen punkt genau da würde ich
an der stelle rang machen genau also das
dankeschön wir machen auch heute im netz
im radio im fernsehen weiter mit
presseclub nachgefragt aber die letzten
worte in dieser sendung gehören nicht
mir sondern einem der großen deutschen
journalisten der letzten jahrzehnte
einem großartigen chef und kollegen
für viele auch für mich persönlich ein
vorbild diese woche ist er im alter von
84 jahren nach langer krankheit
gestorben fritz pleitgen ist wieder bei
uns nicht als ehemaliger wdr-intendant
sondern langjähriger ard-korrespondent
in moskau new york washington und auch
langjähriger gastgeber auf diesem platz
für mich ist eigentlich die hauptsache
dass der krieg für menschen um dort
endlich auf und was dort passiert hunde
skoda und die ukraine wäre aus meiner
sicht ein
fabelhaftes land um eine brücke zu
schlagen zwischen
russland und dem westen dankeschön das
war also mein letzter presseclub künftig
wird monika piel an meiner stelle die
sendung moderieren ich danke für ihr
interesse und ihre unerschütterliche
treue radio
willkommen zurück presseclub nachgefragt
im fernsehen bei phoenix im radio bei
wdr 5 und wir beginnen in bocholt im
münsterland bei elisabeth maier man
vermeiden guten tag sie haben das wort
weil die spd immer für frieden und
dialog stehe
klassen hamlin die eigentlich bekämpft
dankeschön ja dann keine klaren worte
ich glaube ich habe nichts anderes
gesagt ich habe nicht gesagt dass es
hier um waffenlieferungen in vorderster
linie geht sondern dass die spd ihr
stolzes derbe auch der ostpolitik eine
völlig veränderte lage in russland und
der fast schon wieder der sowjetunion ja
anpassen muss und dass die spd durch den
rekurs auf die von willy brandt enorm
verdienstvoll ausgeführte entspannungs
politik an einem verkrampften festhalten
mit einem de facto faschisten wie putin
niemals auf den grünen zweig kommt
insofern war das für mich ein denkanstoß
ich habe ja auch immer auf die sehr
positiven historischen leistungen der
spd bezug genommen und ich glaube vor
diesem hintergrund bleibt die spd sehr
stark hinter ihrem potenzial zu rücken
sofern ist das glaube ich eher eine
aufforderung eine soziale diskussion
innerhalb der sozialdemokratischen
partei sich zu modernisieren aufgrund
der tatsache dass die russen völlig von
der rolle gefallen sind unter putin sie
haben wenn sie mögen noch einmal das
wort vom eiermann
ich danke dass sie den mut hatten das
hier so klar zu sagen wir lassen das
stehen dass es gut dass das teil unserer
debatte ist ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen sonntag und gehe weiter nach
meerbusch bei düsseldorf zu hans meiser
reiser guten tag
grüß gott in die runde ich bin etwas
über irritiert über auch die
kommentierende moderation von ihnen
bezüglich der zuschreibungen das
verhalten von herrn scholz
ich wüsste nicht eine äußerung oder eine
handlung die man mit feigheit oder angst
betiteln könnte ich wüsste auch nicht
woran sie das fest machen wollen und das
zweite ist was es schlecht an absprachen
unter staaten was die waffenlieferung
betrifft nach meiner kenntnis hat keine
der großen länder wie usa großbritannien
et cetera bisher panzer geliefert
wieso hat ein manko der deutschen wenn
sie das nicht tun bitte keine antwort
von dem soester hat vorne liegen ja gut
ich
nehme mal dass das land habe das
nordhäuser
kurze bemerkung von mir persönlich
ich versuche als moderator die
positionen zu beschreiben so wie ich sie
höre so dass sollte einfach zitieren was
hier auch am tisch gesagt wurde aber ich
habe verstanden dass es bei ihnen
missverständlich angekommen ist zur
frage aber was die
waffenlieferung waffenlieferungen die
verbündet der waage ist es ein
alleingang angeht wollte
sie an unsere kameras sind zum teil
versteckt die an das problem nicht habe
sie erwähnt aber sobald sie mit hans
meiser sprechen sie der sie auch danke
für die frage und die frage kommt ja
immer wieder in der tat weder die usa
noch großbritannien noch frankreich nach
italien haben kampfpanzer aus dem
westlicher produktion geliefert im
unterschied polen hat sehr viele andere
aus früheren ostblockländer auch waffen
aus ehemaligen sowjetischen ständen auch
panzer geliefert jetzt zu sagen
deswegen soll diese debatte in
deutschland nicht passieren ist
natürlich ein bisschen ich sage mal
vorsichtig zu kurz gesprungen so gesehen
waren die gepaart flugabwehrkanonen
panzer einen alleingang kein anderes
land hat flugabwehrkanonen panzer
geliefert nur deutschland also da waren
da der alleingang okay jetzt
soll es ihnen nicht geben das ist der
eine punkt der andere punkt ist
deutschland könnte auch etwas initiieren
und zu sagen wir handeln nur in
abstimmung wir machen keine alleingänge
stellt natürlich die frage ja ist denn
deutschland bereit einen solchen
gemeinsamen vorgang zu initiieren ich
habe vorhin schon angedeutet könnte
deutschland als produktionsland der
leopard kampfpanzer vielleicht sagen wir
fragen andere leopard benutzer staaten
ob sie mit uns gemeinsam ein paket
leopard-kampfpanzer bereitstellen das
wäre das gegenteil von einem alleingang
danke herr wiegard herr may sagt kann es
dabei belassen nein wir haben die erste
frage nicht beantwortet nach der
wahrheit und an die zuschauer sie haben
mir redeverbot gegeben
das war eine frage an mich ich habe
versucht zusammenzufassen was herr
richter dargestellt hatte wasser benning
oft gesagt hatte hab versucht die beiden
positionen zuzuspitzen da kann das her
wenn sie es anders nicht so gehört haben
hab ich's nicht gut genug gemacht aber
ich wollte wie ich das an diesem tisch
auftue zusammenfassen herr weise danke
groß nach meerbusch und wir gehen nach
ja immer mal nach ortenberg zu mark
hamill guten tag
ja hallo in die runde sie sind dran am
geschehen hallo in die runde kurze frage
ich war dumm halten krieg 15 monate
bundesluftwaffe
luftabwehr jetzt stehen unsere
benötigten hanser hier um wir mussten
seinerzeit alle sechs wochen die
sogenannte bewegungsart durchführen weil
die hardware sonst verwehren jetzt
stehen die fahrzeuge bei der industrie
bei der bundeswehr überall rum und die
wären nicht geliefert das kann man doch
nicht logisch erklären warum diese
benötigten tatbeute nicht nach der
ukraine liefern die rotten und da werden
gebraucht herbe vielen herzlichen dank
ich nehme das als ihre meinung denn wir
haben ja vor allem darüber gesprochen
dass es politische gründe gibt und geben
kann das nichts zu tun aber danke für
ihre klare position
dann hat uns aus
ostbevern
bernhard klöckner angerufen der mich
jetzt hören ist daher chlubna willkommen
in der sendung vielen dank einem guten
tag alle der geistige ausflug der
richter ist für empathische und dem
menschenrecht unerträglich er könnte
genauso gut für die washington post und
die new york times sprechen
mutmaßlich ist er mitglied der atlantik
brücke und weiß genau was er zu sagen
hat eine reihe hat glaube ich
vorschlagen dadurch kurz unterbrechen
so das sind ja alles
hoch renommierte medien die sie genannt
haben eine wichtige institution und wer
an diesem tisch laden wir kolleginnen
kollegen ein ihre meinung zu sagen und
genau das hat der richter getan
ehrenmitglied ich auch nicht bin bin
vollkommen unabhängig ich habe lange in
den usa gelebt wenn sie meine kommentare
irakkrieg und usa im amerikanischen
fernsehen ansehen würden von damals oder
in amerikanischen zeitungen oder
magazine würden sie sehen dass ich meine
aufgabe darin der irgendwie auch immer
regierung ist dienstlich genau das
wollte ich nicht ich habe heute nicht so
hier darüber diskutieren ob man eine
meinung haben oder sagen darf sondern
mehr laden ein weil wir meinungen höher
sollen so das wollte ich einen verklären
herzklopfen entschuldigung das einfach
als replik von mir und jetzt aber sie
haben ja ein wichtigen inhaltlichen
punkten
ich möchte vorweg noch einen punkt
nennen bevor ich entsprechend das äußere
was sich im vorgespräch gesagt habe ich
bin der meinung sie laden weniger
personen als meinungen ein und die
meinungen passen immer sehr gut zu ihrer
grundaussage die sie tätigen damit
möchte ich dies abschließend meine
ursprüngliche frage die ich im
vorgespräch gesagt hatte auch im
vorgespräch kann dabei auch gesagt sagen
sie bitte nur das was sie auch im
vorgespräch gesagt haben und nichts mehr
es gibt also die leinwand den gesprächen
würden in der sendung die viele anliegen
haben deshalb ist uns immer wichtig
möglichst viele punkte die mit dem thema
zu tun haben hier zu besprechen und sie
möchten aber den blick auf china börsen
so habe ich es verstanden
walter frey konferenz war sicherlich ein
sehr intensives gespräch zwischen putin
und sie zu bemerken
und hat jemand in der diskussionsrunde
daran gedacht dass china durchaus in der
lage ist wirtschaftlich druck aus
deutschland auf zum üben um gewisse
waffen nicht zu liefern china könnte zu
jeder zeit natürlich auch eigene den
eigenen wirtschaftlichen schaden
akzeptieren sagen bitte lieber vw
konzern verlassen sich ina wie sehen sie
diese situation diese beschreibung und
diesen moment ja gebe ich gerne an frau
dornblüth die china ja eben auch schon
als aspekt genannt hat sie haben recht
das wäre möglich zurzeit das ist aber
eher andersherum
es ist so dass china es gab
unbestätigte berichte darüber dass
russland sich im frühjahr an china
gewendet haben soll oben
waffenlieferungen aus china nach
russland das dann hieß es china habe
davon abgesehen also ob das so
stattgefunden hat wissen wir nicht ganz
genau aber was wir wissen ist dass china
sich viele chinesische firmen aus dem
russlandgeschäft zurückgezogen haben
weil ihnen nämlich die wirtschafts
verbindungen mit der eu und mit den usa
die viel größer und wichtiger sind für
china vom umfang her eben wichtiger sind
als putin zu unterstützen und dazu kommt
dass china in der frage des krieges
gegen die ukraine auch nicht gerade auf
russischer seite steht hält sich zurück
hier hat das jetzt auch gerade bei der
bei dem treffen noch mal signalisiert
offensichtlich und nur als hinweis china
hat zum beispiel auch die krim nicht als
russisch anerkannt und hat auch die von
russland unterstützten sogenannten
unabhängigen volksrepublik nicht als
unabhängig zugespitzt wie wichtig ist
die rolle chinas am ende für die
nächsten monate die ist insofern extrem
wichtig als dass der ich sag jetzt mal
politische westen versuchen sollte china
ins boot zu holen um die unterstützung
für russland weiter zu reduzieren
danke frau doppler danke herr klossner
dass sie dabei waren groß nach ostbevern
und die nächste ist doris
gerd in berlin mein bildstörung ist
heute nicht so
schnell wie ich mir das wünsche boris
gerd in berlin guten tag sie haben das
wort ihre meinung ihre frage
die bundeswehr hat kaum waffen
europa die ganzen waffen ab was passiert
denn russland 80 bürger darüber freut
wenn den wir denn die eu verteidigen
müssen den winkel blank wackler agiert
tun haben sie eine meinung dazu haben
naja bundes und landes bündnisse
landesverteidigung ist ja keine sache
die jetzt sozusagen abgeschafft worden
ist das hat man ja das hat man ja im
blick ich bin jetzt keinen ein
militärexperte an der stelle aber
nach allem was ich weiß zumindest ist
die bundeswehr nicht so blank dass das
eintritt was sie gerade besprochen haben
wir ergänzen ja also vielleicht
kurzweilig natürlich in erinnerung habe
wie sehr darüber gesprochen wurde dass
flugzeuge nicht fliegen das panzer nicht
fahren das schiff nicht schwimmen können
ohne die jetzt scheint die bundeswehr
unerschöpflich vorrat sein das ist ja
nicht so als wir müssen erfolgen gesehen
wenn wir uns die liste dessen was
deutschland zugesagt hat und
geliefert hat anschauen dann ist ein
vergleichsweise geringer teil aus der
bundeswehr also aus den streitkräften
der weitaus überwiegende teil der iss in
der liste können sie auf der webseite
der bundesregierung sehen und sternchen
das heißt die industrie wird liefern und
das werden diverse systeme seien eben
weil die bundeswehr diese probleme hat
das was die bundeswehr selber geliefert
hat zum beispiel zehn panzerhaubitzen
die tun der bundeswehr schon weh das ist
richtig aber deswegen ist eben die
entscheidung zu sagen die industrie soll
liefern und nicht die bundes wichtiger
aspekt versuch einer antwort magath
nicht versuch einer antwort sondern eine
kompetente antworten aber immer aber das
thema bleibt schwierig für uns laien
verkehrt grosz nach berlin
und dann sind wir in melle bei osnabrück
und bernhard julius hat das wort
willkommen jahrhundert hat in die runde
meine frage bezüglich
daraufhin meine frage bezieht sich
darauf dass
der einstieg von russland ausgeht und
amerika eine zentrale rolle in den sieg
hat wir sind die mit hören waren und es
ist ja absehbar dass in amerika auch
eine wahl zum präsidenten stattfindet
gibt es nicht ein kurzes zeitfenster nur
in dem der welt mit seinen werten und
mit
dem krieg zu stoppen und etwas
entgegenzusetzen auch militärisch
reagieren kann in der praxis muss in
amerika wieder oberhand gewinnen
präsident geschaltet das ja die bayern
in den mittleren bald schon anzeigen
könnte dann eine ganz andere
ausgangslage ist wenn sich kamp aus der
nato zurück zieht und uns im rechten
rücken julius danke für die frage jetzt
würde ich ja ein richter um antworten
weil er die amerika experte in dieser
jahr und diese frage kann man nur
vollständig in jedem wort zustimmen das
ist eine ganz große ungedeckte flanke
für uns wo wir sehr darauf aufpassen
müssen das sollten wir alle sehr im auge
behalten amerika ist ein sehr diffuses
player und joe biden ist derjenige ddr
vielleicht der letzte große freund
europas ist insofern haben wir alle ein
enormes interesse bevor wir unsere
strategische autonomie und das ganze
worüber herr scholz und helga krohn
gerne reden halbwegs in die trockenen
tücher gepackt haben dass der noch ein
bisschen weiter machen kann das ist für
uns nicht nur für die ukraine ganz
schlacht entscheidend für die freiheit
in europa ja vielen herzlichen dank herr
yannis
zehn sekunden
[Musik]
das ich schließen könnte auch für die
freiheit in deutschland nach hier den
bbi steht in deutschland da wenn ihr
krieg weitergeht moldau gelegen das
alles sei junius unserer sendung
die gibt es aber heute nicht mehr denn
die sendezeit ist vorbei bedanke mich
herzlich wünsche ihnen allen einen
schönen sonntag groß aus köln lassen sie
es gut gehen
[Musik]
wenn es nacht wird auf unserem planeten
schlägt ihre stunde
astro fotografen zeigen uns den
sternenhimmel in spektakulären bildern
[Musik]
der himmel wie wir ihn noch nie gesehen
haben
abenteuerliche reisen durch fünf
kontinente
[Musik]
expedition sternenhimmel